her naptime is it noon so we'll see if  we can get these shots at the end of the  movie when Wonder Woman came out she  completely destroyed Superman I mean she  outdid Superman  I wanted her to have a better role model  better than Douglas out there in the  media it's all about body and image  there's different characteristics that  women are known for that that makes us  MIT that make them strong we need to use  my pregnant wife for this  period in a hole  I mean she loves Disney Princesses but  this specific character Wonder Woman she  was completely obsessed with basically  now she wakes up every single morning  and just as Wonder Woman that's the  first words out of her mouth